we turn our attention now once again to
the biden family syndicate now for two
years we have been actually longer than
that we have been raising concerns about
joe biden's family's sketchy business
partners including
zero experience hunter biden and his
association with the nephew of a
notorious boston gangster and a story
totally ignored by the media mob
remember whitey bulger while his nephew
played a key role in hunter's chinese
ventures here with more fox news
contributor miranda devine along with
former assistant secretary of the
treasury moniker crowley miranda you
wrote the laptop from hell you've seen
the laptop from hell you got a copy of
the laptop from hell my lawyer would not
allow me to take it that's an
interesting story in and of itself
but more importantly
i want to go into this connection
and more importantly than that how it
all ties back to joe biden and how he's
been proven to have lied when he said
he'd never talk to his son about his
foreign business dealings
well look sean i think it's pretty clear
that joe biden
did have a lot to do with hunter biden's
overseas business partners he met many
of them he met them from all sorts of
countries ranging from china to russia
to ukraine and kazakhstan and
mexico
and he met he met one of his business
partners in beijing when he flew hunter
in to china on air force two
with him when he was going to have some
high level meetings with president xi
jinping and the ccp so
it just does not pass the sniff test
it's kind of absurd that the white house
is still trying to run that line that
joe biden
knew nothing about his son hunter's
overseas business dealings he knew
exactly what was well maybe he didn't
know the
details but he knew what hunter was up
to and he was doing it in his name
we have pictures monica crowley of joe
biden with foreign business partners
from mexico and foreign business
partners from kazakhstan but and and the
lecture that he gave his his
mexican business partner which was oh
i've brought you to the white house all
these times i brought you to meet my
father all these times what you haven't
given me anything yet so clearly there
was a quid pro quo expectation
here's my question though
with all the money that this family
syndicate got from china and in the
deals they got from china and the money
they got from a russian oligarch former
first lady of moscow millions of dollars
the money they got from a kazakhstan
oligarch the millions that hunter got
from ukraine with barista and joe
leverages a billion taxpayer dollars to
fire the prosecutor investigating his
son being paid millions with no
experience
if the name was trump and it was donald
trump jr or eric trump or ivanka trump
or barron trump or tiffany trump don't
you think the media would handle this a
lot differently
i think that question answers itself
sean i think the answer is very obvious
that of course if this were any member
of the trump family
there would be we'd be on the 15th
impeachment of donald trump expos facto
look the double standard is so clear
we've got deep deep corruption
corruption with this family that's gone
on for decades influence peddling is the
biden family business we've got long
paper trails sean of the corruption of
not just hunter but joe i mean this is a
joe biden story and we know the famous
10 for the the big guy but now we've
also got emails and texts indicating
that joe biden had hunter the bag man
for the biden family actually turning
over 50.
their ill-gotten gains okay
wouldn't there be shouldn't there be an
investigation
is joe biden compromised by china and
russia and ukraine and kazakhstan
because that's really the question here
it would appear according to these
emails he not only knew what he profited
from these deals that would mean that we
potentially have a president that is
completely compromised
where's that investigation i think there
is an investigation going on in delaware
uh into hunter biden and various aspects
of his foreign business dealings and i
think that from the questions that we
understand have been asked of uh some of
the witnesses uh such as who is the big
guy it seems that they are starting to
look at joe biden because joe biden is
the big guy as tony bobolinsky told us
monica crowley thank you miranda always
great to see you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else